the jurgen experience chris rock said
one of the most mild
jokes ever it was pretty mild
is uh bald apparently i didn't know this
i found out after the fact that it's she
didn't shave her head voluntarily she
shaved her head because she's suffering
from alopecia i didn't know this either
so i don't know if chris knew this
uh but chris says
a joke around uh gi gi jane two looking
forward to it very mild just laughed and
even said come on that was nice
and then will smith initially laughed
yes but it looked like jada was upset
and so will changes his tune
walks on stage and smacks chris rock in
the face at the oscars
uh and then says keep my wife's name out
of your [ __ ] mouth yes he does and
then he goes come on man that was a gi
jane joke he and he screams it out like
keep my
name out your [ __ ] mouth yeah he's
like his lips were quivering and he
first of all
that is a
that whole scene doing that in that
manner in that place
is a great example of what's wrong with
the
the
glorification
of just being able to go up to someone
and smack them in the face because that
is that that whole thing was so
difficult to agree with you here please
do well what is your time i want to let
you
well no you said you're going to
disagree with me what do you think well
i i don't actually think there's any
glorification of violence
in the sense of
free capability on on will's part
what do you mean by that well
for one
i
i don't think that there was any
inherent given that you could just get
away with it i think that whatever will
did he did it and he was like whatever
comes with it
that that you know i'll have to own up
to it i don't think he was thinking that
far ahead at all maybe he wasn't but i
think he's like emotionally fragile
probably and he acted on impulse sure i
think it's a foolish impulse that you
you do when you know there's no
consequences i don't think here's the
thing i'm going to say that i don't know
that he thinks that there's now in terms
of hitting chris
in in terms of them in their physical
differences and capability of of combat
let's say yes there's no concept but i'm
saying but well but there's no
consequences in getting out of your seat
and striking somebody on national
television yeah but i don't think he was
thinking about that i think he was
acting impulsively in terms of yeah
man to man and what who's capable and
what's capable and you know what that
may
be the case um in in in the microcosm of
things but
if you hit anybody for any reason in
public at this point you have the the
very real fact of
all of the powers of law that be
especially depending on who you were who
you are and what the public and the
cathedral thinks of you
smashing you to death until you have
your penniless bankrupt
and everyone helping you stop that's not
going to happen here
it's never going to happen obviously you
just smacked him
out you didn't beat the [ __ ] out of him
he didn't harm him
we live in a society where violence is
so
but there's no way stop there's no way
will smith's gonna become penniless from
smacking chris rock that was never you
would never you wouldn't think he's
extremely wealthy it's not gonna happen
and not only that chris rock instantly
didn't press charges he wouldn't press
charges and he just accepted it i would
say it should have been handled
in in in the back or he could have at
least
he could have step stood up said
something right on the spot but listen
no not done anything about it or
you don't go and sit in the front row
you're a star at the oscars there's a
professional comedian whose job is to
roast people that's what he's doing and
what he did was not even insulting it's
not it was a mild joke it's not about
what is it it's not about giving
will smith a pass or saying what he did
was right but what i am saying is that
from his perspective if it was that
important
he could have he could have
barring going up there and hitting chris
in front of everyone
and
he could have at lea he could have he
could have said something if he had to
do it right then and there
uh if he felt that it was that egregious
of of a remark and i agree with you
chris rock's a comedian the presenters
at the oscars are supposed to be
entertainers
often crack jokes that either a that
they do themselves in chris's
perspective or from chris's situation or
ones that are written for him
chris is a comedian i highly doubt that
they don't know each other at this point
being in hollywood for as long as they
have
and in my opinion if you really want to
settle things
go do it personally speak to the person
first give them an opportunity to
apologize for things especially if they
didn't realize that what they were doing
was i hear all the things you're saying
but they're not applicable that was not
an insult it was the most mild joke
about her hairstyle i fully get into a
movie where lily she shaved her head i
fully get it but i'm doing it
any justification whatsoever of him
getting up there and smacking him in the
face
he didn't need to go up there and smack
him at all no but
regardless of what you and i think of
how important or how
what the what the weight of what chris
said was
just taking removing us out of the
equation if it's really that important
to jada
and therefore then becomes important to
will then he should deal with it on a
personal level and have a conversation
with chris before
anything of course because you have to
give someone the opportunity because
one you have to assume
potentially that that chris had
malicious intent in what he had to say
what how do you have malicious intent in
a mild joke because
i'm saying i don't agree with that he's
telling you dude this is all rational
thinking about an irrational act
that was he was emotionally fragile and
he acted on impulse in a staggeringly
stupid way i'll tell you something
somebody a good dude
who i know didn't mean any harm
was kind of you know playfully
verbally sparring with with my
girlfriend
and she did actually it made her really
uncomfortable and she didn't really like
it and so the next time we run into them
and
my girlfriend's like i hope he doesn't
you know come up and say xyz again i'm
like
i don't i don't think that's going to
happen and
he does and i'm like
okay so i pull him to the side and i'm
like hey look i know you don't mean
anything by it but you know xyz and we
just have a simple conversation and the
guy's just like yeah yeah i don't want
to have a question but that's a rational
response
to
two human beings having some sort of a
dispute but to assume people
have malicious intent especially in that
position
i think is an erroneous way of
approaching it so i don't think i don't
think it had anything to do with that i
think what he was doing so you don't
think saving face you think so he was
doing some weird movie thing it was like
he was getting away with it as if he was
living in a fictional movie like the
idea that you think it's smart while
wearing a tuxedo to walk onto a stage in
front of the world like literally the
world one of the biggest award shows on
earth if not the biggest and smack a
comedian for the most mild joke and then
sit there quivering saying keep my
wife's name out of your [ __ ] mouth
and everybody's just gonna sit there in
the [ __ ] that you just took on the table
you just pulled your pants down and took
a [ __ ] on the dinner table and they all
have just sit there and look at that
that's what it's like she's full of
peanuts and corn and everything stinks
it's just the whole idea behind me is
completely irrational but what i'm
saying is like these people live in this
fake world of you know
you're you're protected by guards you're
driven by limos you're on the red carpet
you know like all of it is crazy life
and he's so goddamn famous and so
so removed from regular discourse and
interaction with regular people that he
for whatever reason in his head acted
like he's a character in a movie maybe
so and and i only am not speaking in
definites in regards to will because i
don't know the man i never met him
all these things that you're saying
could could absolutely be 100 plausible
and true and especially a person like
will who is in such an elevated position
in society at large
and
you are 100 right in that these
types of folks
get removed from reality um for a
variety of reasons
but it's often a catastrophic process to
the person and how they approach the
world but here's what happened right
afterwards he won the academy award then
goes up and does a speech
the whole thing was so bizarre and it
made me think like how many other human
beings could be in a similar situation
and pull that off
like if a man walked on stage and
smacked a woman no that would not fly
would not fly not fly if a woman walked
on stage and smacked another woman i
don't even think it would fly probably
not probably not but but also
man smacking a woman we already like
it's i feel like it's even an ingrained
thing like you don't [ __ ] do that
number two women smacking women
all the women are going to look back and
be like women don't solve their their
issues with violence you're supposed to
you know tear them down in in other ways
and like women
when women
start feuding with one another and one
of them finally says that's it and they
go to violence it's almost as if they
they lost completely like all the other
women are like ah you're broke sorry
you're out
well i don't know i'm just simply
because women are just world star
hip-hop videos of women beating the [ __ ]
out of each other you can find a lot of
videos online of you know women in
walmart parking lots pulling each
other's hair yes there are exceptions i
will agree
i will agree but i just think so in
terms of society standards i don't think
they would have accepted it the same way
no it's like it was a rare instance
where someone is so enormously famous
and successful like will smith that they
literally still allowed him to not just
win the academy award but also go up and
accept it and give a speech after he
assaulted a small comedian yeah they
should have rejected him they should
have ejected him from the show 100
100
i agree with that you don't you can't
just go smack a man in the face in front
of the world and then go about business
as usual first of all it sets a terrible
precedent yes in in so many different
ways it's a terrible precedent for
comedy clubs yes like are people gonna
decide that they're gonna go on stage
and smack the comedian i hope they try
to smack brendan or you
just want to see one joe rogan turning
sidekick yeah
chuggy i i don't
i don't necessarily think people are
going to change their behavior but dumb
people might but also it's like what are
we saying as a society when the the
people that we look up to for whatever
reason for good or for bad we look up to
actors yes and and the academy awards is
supposed to be them in their most regal
their most regal outfits their best
behavior and to
drop down to violence for something so
innocuous as a gi jane joke it's look
man it's not the hill that i'm looking
to necessarily die on either
in term whatever the in particular
context and and
you know
i had you know having a conversation
with somebody over something that
was
what made my girlfriend uncomfortable
was to me that was the way to approach
it but i guess
if someone would you know want to tell
me [ __ ] you about it then it's like um
okay well now that changes things right
okay you don't care how it affects other
people and you're not actually have you
having consideration for me or my
girlfriend or i know what you're saying
but in this case we saw it no we see all
the elements laid out this fox joke was
yes so mine i get it and so
you know jade is allowed to take offense
and will's allowed to take offense but
to jump up
run on stage slap him and then throw the
scene that he did is a completely
different story it was a meltdown to at
least to go and give chris an
opportunity to talk to him and maybe
even jada and just be like look one
you can see that he did not mean to try
and cause any actual harm to you so you
know what just tell him if you didn't
like it
tell him face to face and be like yo man
it really you know hey that would be
really buggy you're talking about two
totally different things we both agree
with that but to be agree regardless of
whether you're will smith or your or
your your uh
um
the other will smith
the the former like special forces guy
who speaks russian was in all tons of
like 70s and 80s movies he played
conan's dad and conan the barbarian like
that badass [ __ ] you could be
that guy the this other super popular
will smith or will smith that nobody
actually knows who that person is
the approach has to be the same there is
no exception for you if you played ali
or if you played conan's dad or if
nobody's seen you play anything even
with yourself well i think what we're
looking at also is the culmination of a
long period of like emotional distress
like that family's been public about all
their issues and you know there's a
conversation that they had to have like
the two of them together about
infidelity
open relationships and they were openly
mocked because of that but i think
there's a certain defensiveness that
comes along with that well then you know
what i've been out in the public [ __ ]
sitting out in the public getting mocked
sit in it then sit in it then because
the public is mocking you for the thing
that you brought to them yeah listen i'm
i'm gonna
so for me i'm like look if you think
you're if you're
adding stress into your life by
publicizing and externalizing everything
which again says something more about
the state of things like why are you
externalizing this [ __ ] right you know
what i mean like even when i told this
story about oh you know this fighter and
i had beef
i ain't going to say his name right
because you know what i'm not trying to
create more beef right because
i'm not trying to live my life even
though i'm the war master and some point
of irrational unnecessary conflict when
conflict comes conflict if if it has to
get to that yes then that's my whole
point let's destroy everything you're a
man of honor and of like deep moral
principles and ethics you you have a
very rigid way you live your life with
discipline that's my whole point of this
yes this is a nonsense you're right
where you're allowed to just go smack
someone you're right